there's a character in here the landlord
who I mean I'll just say it you read it
you go I pretty sure that's Donald Trump
or you're you're you jazz riffing on
Donald Trump is that fair to say
does that seem like it's a fair
characterization well I mean as it is a
book of fiction I think you know you you
as you're right you have certain models
that you asked me in the break about the
white you know what face I had in mind
when I was thinking about my lead
character Bob honey and what all I can
say is I had for the for the character
you're talking about the landlord I had
sort of a bloated orange walrus and and
and if that therefore reflects anybody
familiar you know I think it's a fair
interpretation
just glad it wasn't me you're not
bloated no give me four years
you